It's common knowledge that the inhumanities
carried out by the Nazi party under the reign
of Adolf Hitler during the second wold war
were unspeakably horrific.
But here's some little known facts about Hitler
and the Nazi party that you may not know.
1.
During World War II, Nazi scientists developed
an experimental cocktail of drugs, containing
oxycodone, cocaine and methamphetamine.
When they gave the cocktail to test subjects
they gained almost superhuman powers and were
able to march over 90 kilometres a day, whilst
carrying a 20 kilogram backpack, without any
fatigue.
2.
When Berlin fell two Nazi submarines declined
to surrender and instead remained submerged
for two months before landing in Argentina,
one is said to have offloaded a Nazi officer
before it was detected.
3.
In 1945, US president Dwight D. Eisenhower
predicted that people would try to dispel
the fact that the holocaust ever actually
happened.
So he ordered innumerable pictures to be taken
of the Nazi crimes to hinder any such attempts.
4.
A German soldier during WW2 called Werner
Goldberg was branded "The Ideal German Soldier"
because of his physical appearance.
Ironically he was half Jewish.
5.
The Nazis were animal lovers.
Many Nazi leaders, including Hitler and Hermann
Göring, were ardent supporters of animal
rights and conservation.
The Nazi party even introduced animal protection
laws and laws that limited the hunting of
animals.
Hitler himself even became a vegetarian towards
the later stages of his life.
It's just a shame they didn't realise that
humans are animals too.
6.
In 1939 the Nazis formed a plan to counterfeit
the British pound to cause hyperinflation
and send the British economy into meltdown.
Using a German concentration camp, they manufactured
over 132 million British Pound Sterling, which
is the equivalent of 7 billion pounds today.
Their plan was a partial success.
7.
The Nazis believed that Germans as a race
were superior to all other human beings.
But it wasn't only Germans that became Nazis.
The Nazis kidnapped hundreds of thousands
of Polish children whom they deemed to be
racially superior and forcibly Germanised
them.
After the war ended only 10% of them ever
returned to Poland.
Which is a striking example of the Nazis brainwashing
power.
8.
The Nazis were obsessed with invading Switzerland.
It's no secret the Nazis were always fond
of a good invasion.
By June 1941 they had invaded and occupied
Belgium, the Netherlands, Luxembourg, France,
Greece, Denmark, Yugoslavia, Norway and Poland.
Switzerland however has a famous, long standing
neutrality, it never takes sides.
But the Nazis had no intentions of respecting
that.
Hitler hated Switzerland, he called it "A
pimple on the face of Europe".
They put all their efforts into invading it,
but it wasn't an easy task, due to Switzerland
being surrounded by perilous mountains, so
they eventually gave up.
9.
Hitler loved a good joke.
Hitler had a small collection of favourite
jokes that he enjoyed telling over and over
again.
His all time favourite was:
One day, Mrs. Goering came into the bedchamber
and found her husband waving his Field Marshall‘s
baton over his underwear.
“Hermann, darling, what are you doing?”
she enquired.
“I am promoting my underpants to overpants!”
10.
The German's gravely feared and hated secret
police force, the Gestapo, was headed by Heinrich
Müller.
Widely regarded as a purely evil individual
who presided over countless tortures and executions
during the war.
Müller was seen in Hitler's bunker the day
after his suicide, but after that he completely
vanished, never to be seen again.
To this day his is the most senior member
of the Nazi regime who's whereabouts are not
known.
Many people involved with the Nazi regime
have said they believe he is still alive and
it is rumoured he escaped to South America.
But he still manages to elude police detectives.
11.
When the Nazi party held its first book burning,
one of the works destroyed was a 1821 play
by Heinrich Heine, which contained the famous
line: "When they burn books, they will in
the end, also burn people."
12.
The United States gave asylum to Nazi war
criminals for decades and subsequently tried
to cover it up until they were sued under
the Freedom of Information Act.
13.
Although widely disputed, it is thought that
Nazi doctors were the first to identify the
link between smoking and lung cancer.
Because of this the Nazis were very anti-smoking
and launched one of the first ever known anti-smoking
campaigns.
14.
The Nazis tried to cure homosexuality by forcing
homosexual inmates to have sex with female
sex slaves.
15.
Coco Chanel, founder of the Chanel Brand was
a Nazi Spy.
Chanel loved power, so naturally she found
a home amongst the Nazi officials.
Not only did Chanel steal her famous perfume,
Chanel No.5 from the Jewish family that financed
it, but she also got them to pay her living
expenses.
16.
The Nazis planned to turn the whole of Moscow
and Warsaw into artificial lakes.
17.
The Nazis were responsible for a lot of advances
in technology.
Hitler commissioned the designer of porsche
to create an everyday car that looked like
a beetle.
This was the start of Volkswagen, literally
meaning "People's Car".
The new car was a huge success and became
one of the most popular vehicles in the world.
18.
Hitler was also an enthusiastic supporter
for the construction of autobahns, he pushed
for the world's largest network of roads to
be built across Germany.
Being the first ever freeway system the autobahn
was a legendary feat of engineering that has
since been emulated by Britain and America.
19.
A member of the Nazi party was also responsible
for creating modern day rocketry as we know
it.
Aerospace engineer Wernher Von Braun, was
a member of the Nazi party who basically fathered
modern day rocketry.
Since WW2 he has become a U.S. citizen working
at NASA, and he developed the Saturn V booster
rocket, that helped man finally reach the
moon.
20.
After the Second World War, more than 7,000
Nazi sympathisers committed suicide.
21.
In addition to six million jews, the Nazis
also killed an equal number of Christians,
Catholics and Homosexuals inside concentration
camps.
22.
And finally, pretty much every Nazi official
who knew Hitler didn't like his moustache.
But Hitler loved it.
His secretary once outwardly told him that
she didn't like his moustache, to which Hitler
replied "If the moustache is not a trend now,
it will become one soon because I am wearing
it."